oh hello there you may be wondering why
the pink suit so the world can see that
I have a big ol heart on that's heart
with the T for my new obsession pink the
color not the pop singer personally I'm
more of a saline kind of guy
pink is hide like a beautiful ribbon to
a cause very close to me cancer so
amazed and I are joining together scare
up some serious cash
for [ __ ] cancer I'm gonna donate the
very suit off my back while giving you a
chance to own some movie marketing
memorabilia what you do from there is
limited only by your imagination will
you add it to your weekly wardrobe
rotation who doesn't become a colorful
addition to your S&M dungeon oh you
simply nail it to a post in order to
scare away birds children and the
elderly visit the website below to get
all the details this is one fight where
everyone can be a hero no superpowers
capes or lame CG costumes needed just
your money seriously we need that these
suits aren't cheap
at do amazed calm forward slash Deadpool
and together let's f cancer calm
you